la très grande majorité de l'ail
consommés au québec provient de
l'étranger de la chine notamment
mais de plus en plus laïdi ci se taille
une place
reflets d'une industrie jeune et
dynamique
stiles a réussi à conserver en main en
soirée
j'ai vu arriver avec deux belles banda
et je me suis dit c'est pas ça je m'en
veux aussi
les gens sont épicurienne de plus en
plus veulent goûter les produits frais
veulent un contact avec le producteur
donc là il doit être construit dans un
endroit si depuis huit ans le s'est
passé ici pour notre personnel de trois
arcs à peu près trente ans que j'en
manque à chaque année de l'âge à la
demande
[Musique]
cédric paris aime le contact avec la
nature
les faits ne n'ai pas cessé des cinq
étapes le soir profitez du soleil
couchant
donc c'est quelque chose qui me permet
de me raccrocher à la terre
pour lui la production d'ail relève plus
du loisir que du travail
cédric est chimiste le jour
rien à voir avec l'agriculture ça me
fait du bien de sortir du monde du
travail puis de rentrer dans le monde
agricole de toucher la terre de
travailler avec les éléments de la
nature en train de séparer les bulbes
d'ail en cailloux ce qu'ils vont
permettre et la particularité dallas
c'est quand la plante à l'automne son
intérêt pour la culture die
il l'a découvert en discutant avec un
agronome il ya quinzaine d'années
aujourd'hui cédric et sa conjointe de
plantes environ 6000 bulbes sur cette
parcelle qu'il loue à un agriculteur
dans la banlieue nord de québec
[Musique]
la monoculture que je fais je viens ici
avec mon chien puis l'a titré mais je
peux travailler par les soirs de semaine
et ça me permet de de d'avoir menti
production aussi en fait cédric a le
profil type d'une majorité de
producteurs d'ail ou québec jeunes
exploitants père de famille qui
travaille sans machinerie sur une petite
surface pour une offre de proximité
je m'identifie à ce titre de producteur
là je suis sur plusieurs réseaux en fait
de producteurs ou que les gens se posent
des questions se répondent et cetera
donc on voit un certain intérêt au
niveau des jeunes de daloa de la micro
production et dans le domaine de l'oeil
mais là il se reproduit assez faciles à
écouler là
facile à écouler ce n'est pas peu dire
l'engouement actuel pour lie au québec
ne ment pas une production totale qui
est passé d'une trentaine d'hectares en
2003 à plus de 200 hectares aujourd'hui
c'est cette fois plus en parcelles de
culture le produit de la et du québec
gagnent en popularité
de plus en plus versus delahaye importés
parce que les gens veulent des produits
de qualité voit la différence aussi
ghout la différence geneviève legault
est agronome au ministère de
l'agriculture des pêcheries et de
l'alimentation
on l'a rencontré à martinsville dans les
cantons de l'est
aujourd'hui elle supervise une
intervention de fertilisation biologique
sur les terres d'un producteur d'ail
l'un des plus gros au québec et ce
qu'elle constate chez ces producteurs
c'est une croissance de production qui
se serait même accentuée depuis un an
oui on observe il ya beaucoup d'intérêts
de l'apport de plusieurs types de
producteurs à se lancer dans la
production de l'aïe
soit des démarrages
il ya des gens de la relève c'est une
majorité de petits producteurs
c'est sûr que quand même des gros
producteurs le pour approvisionner les
marchés et les chaînes épicerie ça peut
aussi voir sébastien grammond et l'un de
ses écrous producteurs en 2010 ils
achètent la ferme le petit mas une
pionnière dans la culture die biologique
au québec
l'agriculteur produit aujourd'hui dix
fois plus die qu'à ses débuts il y a dix
ans oui vraiment une augmentation de
production là au québec
vague sur les aliments du québec des
aliments locaux donc la provenance est
de plus en plus important pour les
québécois dans tous les dom je pense
donc là et embarquer un peu là dedans
sébastien a été président de
l'association des producteurs d'ail du
québec
la majorité des 170 membres sont de
jeunes maraîchers comme lui et cédric
c'est une culture qui nous permet de
faire du bio sans avoir trop de
contraintes
ça se fait bien je dirais des plus
petits producteurs sont intéressés par
la production la terre que ce soit de
l'ail le miel tout des productions qui
peuvent se vendre directement la ferme
ou en ligne
une offre qui plaît à une clientèle déjà
familière avec le marché des péni bio
disponibles dans leur localité
c'est vraiment les jeunes sont plus
portés aller chercher leurs légumes les
paniers bio tout ça
[Musique]
au ministère de l'agriculture on
commence à parler d'une certaine
pression voire même une saturation du
marché de la halle cultivés au québec
notamment en raison des faibles
quantités qu'on achète généralement le
couple ou une famille vont manger à peu
près en kilos d'ail par année donc c'est
pau
c'est pas des grosses quantités c'est un
condiment on sait que les prix sont très
différents de l'importer donc
il faut que les attributs le
quand on veut vraiment le les
consommateurs en effet le prix n'est pas
l'argument de vente le plus convaincant
pour ceux qui veulent essayer l'ail du
québec un prix franchement plus élevé
que l'aïe en provenance des autres pays
par contre les producteurs d'ici vous
diront que le rail se conserve bien plus
longtemps que l'ail importés si vous
appliquez les règles je vous ai donné là
il va rester très ferme et utilisables
durant toute l'année prochaine moi je
reste à la conserver un an sans problème
la bonne nouvelle c'est que les
québécois peut encore aller chercher des
parts de marché puisque seulement 12 %
de tous là et consommés au québec est
produit dans la province 12% nous
provient des autres provinces
canadiennes 20% de l'espagne 8% d'autres
pays comme le portugal le mexique et
l'argentine
tout le reste soit près de la moitié de
l'ail que nous consommons chez nous nous
prouve y est de la chine
[Musique]
longtemps éclipsée dans les supermarchés
par un alain portes et moins coûteux là
et du québec gagnent du terrain dans les
grandes chaînes d'alimentation
je voudrais c'est très régionale au
niveau de la disponibilité de l'ail du
québec nous auto en estrie étant donné
qu'on a beaucoup de producteurs c'est
pas difficile de trouver de l'est du
québec dans nos épiceries
presque toutes les bannières le tiennent
ces poissons pour cent corps des chaînes
je pense qu'ils ont des lettres du
québec pendant la haute saison
mais après octobre plus on avance vers
noël et puis après la pression n'est
plus dans l'esprit certains producteurs
comme sébastien ne cachent pas leur
désir de rendre leur production
disponible partout dans le marché durant
les quatre saisons
ça sera d'avoir de l'est du québec plus
longtemps dans les chaînes et dans les
marchés publics qui seront encore
ouverts le denek sont ouverts plus
longtemps d'avoir de l'est du québec à
la nuit j'ai commencé avec un drap de
lin aujourd'hui plus d'une douzaine
d'heures moi personnellement ce qui
m'accrochent beaucoup à ça c'est de voir
comment la clientèle répond bien
[Musique]